découvrir des filières se renseigner sur
une école ou définir son projet
d'orientation le salon de l'étudiant se
tenait ce week-end au Vélodrome national
un moment clé pour les collégiens et
lycéens qui se posent de nombreuses
questions qu'il a 14 ans il a de très
bonnes notes mais il sait pas dans quel
domaine s'orienter encore je viens voir
si il y avait un métier qui
m'intéresserait au pouvoir pour des
études pour plus tard
le fait que ça soit quand même très
rapide tous les choix qu'on a à faire et
que on nous force un peu à trouver des
orientations assez rapidement quoi plus
d'une quarantaine de stand étaient
présents et plusieurs conférences se
sont tenues pour informer les étudiants
un moment important notamment pour les
élèves de terminale qui doivent réaliser
leurs vœux sur la plateforme parcoursup
le but vraiment de ce salon c'est de
permettre aux étudiants de d'avoir
toutes les informations en fait dans un
même lieu c'est le début des choix et le
but c'est de leur permettre d'avoir
vraiment un lieu d'échanges et d'avoir
toutes les informations pour qu'ils
puissent s'orienter par la suite au
total ils étaient plus de 4000 et pour
ceux qui n'ont pas eu la possibilité de
venir d'autres événements auront lieu
dans les Yvelines comme la soirée des
métiers de l'orientation qui se tiendra
au Centre sportif Pierre de Coubertin à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le 25 janvier